hello everyone yesterday have you seen
the first game ever played between Garry
Kasparov and Magnus Carlsen it was
played on 17th of March 2014 Reykjavik
and this is the second game they played
it was played the day after this is the
18th of March and it's around one of the
Reykjavik open tournament
it's the rapid tournament so in this
game Kasper also has the white pieces
but I will show a one more game where
Carlson has the white pieces this game
as Barbara opens with C for the English
opening we have Knight to f6 Knight to
c3 and g6 and it's very important to
stay that there were no real mistakes
made this game only you know tiny
inaccuracies efore we have d6 d4 Bishop
to g7 by Carlsen and the game now
transposed into the Kings Indian defense
we have Knight to f3 crossing castles
Bishop to e2 5 and Bishop to e3 this is
the glitch system for Kings Indian
defense it captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and c6 f3 it's a useful
move f3 it reinforces d4 pawn also
doesn't allow this Knight any Knight to
g4 jumps to harass the dark square
Bishop rook to e8 by Carlsen and we have
Bishop to f2 and this Bishop to f2 is
also a very nice move as it after this
epon is exchanged the bishop will no
longer be a target for the rook and the
e-file also it will come in very handy
as a defensive piece later on d5 by
Carlsen eke after sandy 5c after sandy
fat and c5 like a sparrow now and we
have a knight to c6 Knight B to d7 seems
like seems like a better move it attacks
this weird c5 pawn but Casper can simply
push it to c6 or simply play Knight to
b3 now it's defended twice by the knight
and the bishop so Knight to c6 is
perfectly fine by Carlsen we have
castles by Kasparov Knight to h5 now
going for that very nice f4 square
Queen to d2 defending the f4 square and
now Bishop to e5 now adding more
pressure to the f4 square preparing a
move like Knight to f4 and here cuz
power plays g3 stops the idea better
place 3 by Carlsen
we have rook F to e 1 and this isn't
like the really critical moment of the
game but it's a very interesting moment
in the game here at cross and play
tonight the g7 the idea is that as part
of could push something like f4
attacking the bishop on e5 and also
discovering an attack on the night on h5
so here nice Knight to g7 was played but
also an idea was Queen to a5 because
this F form maybe isn't that powerful as
it seems
for example Bishop to g7 now Bishop
captures on h5 and after G captures on
h5 ok this is a pretty shattered
position but blacks position doesn't
seem that bad across and still has this
very strong bishop on g7
the Queen can either do something on the
Queen side or she can go back Queen c7
Queen to d8
this is a very strong Bishop on h3 and
also some ideas like h4 could be
possible so it's it's not at all clear
how how much better white here is or is
he even better but okay I have to look
after he won cousin play Knight to g7
stopping this idea rook a to D 1 by
Kasparov and rook to c8 and we have
Knight B to D 5 a 6 and here comes power
plays Knight to d6 it seems like
Carlsen will win a pawn now so bit of
characters on d6 see captors on d6 and
here Carlsen play d4 if Queen captures
then simply Knight captures nothing
nothing is happening here but here car
someplace a move d4 and this d4 move is
a very poisonous move it comes with a
very devious idea what happens if you
capture the pawn if you capture the
phone pawn with Bishop captures on d4
after night after Sunday for and Queen
captures on d4 you get Knight to f5 this
comes with a wood with an attack on the
Queen and also put an attack on the d6
pawn and now this Queen has a problem
you can't really defend at this point
you'd have to
the Queen if you play something like
Queen to d5 you get night to e3 and now
you're losing the exchange if instead of
Queen there you play something like
Queen to d2
now comes Queen to b6 check and after
King to h1 now comes Queen to have to
threaten in Bishop - G - checkmate
and after you stop this Bishop to f1 now
comes Queen captures rook captures rook
captures rook captures and out Bishop
captures an f1 and Carlsen wins a piece
here on the other hand after Knight to
f5 if you play something like Queen to
d3 this is losing instantly because now
after Queen to b6 check and King to h1
and after Queen to f2 there's still the
threat of Bishop to g2 checkmate in now
after we play Bishop to f1 you you
simply lose an entire Rock Road captures
row chapters Queen captures another
thing that we should point out is that
if you defended this with something like
rook to g1 you can also defend checkmate
like this but then after night to e3
there is no defense against Bishop to g2
white would have to give up the Queen
with Queen capture screen captures and
it's simply a completely winning
position for black but after this d4
move Casper oh of course didn't capture
it he played Knight to e4 and now white
is clearly better here Carlsen played
Bishop to a5 we have d7 now Bishop
captures because if you don't capture
with the bishop if you capture with the
Queen then Knight to f6 check you lose
the Queen
so after this Bishop to a5 move and the
d7 cross and play Bishop captures on d7
but now comes Bishop captures on d4 the
threat is now of course Knight to f6
winning the exchange Knight captures
Queen captures and now Carson is losing
the exchange of whatever he plays since
the bishop is attacked by the Queen and
the rook if you try and defend this the
threat is still Knight to f6 check if
you try to block this with the rook the
knight to f6 check and again there is
now a triple attack on the bishop on b7
so once again Carson is now losing a
whole piece so instead of this after
Queen to d4 Carlsen doesn't want to give
up the exchange he plays
Knight to f5 and he decides to sacrifice
a piece now
casparo of course captures that Queen
character son d7 we have Queen to b6
came to h1 as it's it came with check
rot e to d8 now attacking the Queen
Queen to a4 rook captures Queen captures
and Queen captures and b2 and here you
can see that Carlson is up one pawn but
he's still down a piece so a pawn for a
piece without any any real compensation
it's it's not that much Queen to be won
Casper offers the exchange of Queens
also protects the a to pawn
we have rook to c2 Queen captures rook
captures and Bishop to c4 defending the
a to pawn if if Carson could somehow
grab despondent maybe to best bonds
could be compensation for the piece but
to which this a2 upon still on the board
it's very unlikely cross and play Knight
to d4 going after this f3 pawn and here
Kasparov played rook to e3 and in this
position Magnus Carlsen resigned to the
game so there is really nothing for for
black to hope for here I mean a piece up
is just too much you can't even push
something like b5 simply Bishop to b3
and still always well even if you
capture a captures the point is
protected so I mean he could stall this
but it would be just a slow painful
death so yeah this is the second game to
have them played together and yet again
the victory goes to Garry Kasparov I
will show one more game it was also from
this event the 2004 rapid tournament in
Reykjavik I do hope you enjoyed this
game I would like to thank Anna Skye
Sony Patrick Brennan John Hampton and
Edward song for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon